Yeah, this set of brushes from the TikTok shop is a whole.
It's like 40. It's a whole 40 piece set.
Not only the brushes, it comes with a ton of brushes,
the makeup sponges, these, like,
powder pressing things and.
And it comes with a bunch.
I still haven't even used all of them.
Things to wash your face, things to clean the brushes.
This thing is a huge. And they're nice brushes.
They're synthetic, really nice brushes.
They really work well.
I just have a lot of options now when I'm doing my makeup,
and I love it. It's linked here in the TikTok shop.
It is a bajillion brushes,
all the different shapes, sizes,
anything you could want. And sponges and powder applicators.
Like, I feel like a professional MUA and shit.